THEIR FORTUNES THROUGH INCOMES E
UNQUOTE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> W THINK THERE ARE TWO
THINGS ON THE PRO PUBLICA
REPORT.
THE FIRST THAT THE TAX CODE IS
D HETHE INRSUI
MOS Y CC MALT BERTH TNE 2
SE 'SGAASLITHTAEDH.HAPE TLOFF D
T  CO E NELE OD WA T
GHEO OSE AEDRA
ET O
H  AO
CA ACTE K H HA TRYN ASIFYITHEYND
WH
NSF SLURNCATN CHHTT AN TOBF
BITA U
TH HITE  TFI'SFRT  E AY O  OUEV
HI
T, CL. AU TH FS.WIRS TO ND IE A
M.E
TASCL, $ONITTH CIAXUSLEERHEASSIH
ARHOTW
MOR YO
TH PSER ESNG AY IV
OICONOT
ASASAYFETR
T.F CAOR YTHAVONAVTHS WHTONOAV
INEMTHPLTHNGLWSE
YOHEH ONTHLDE LA T
TOERIS I
O ARINLO
SOTEAN IBU18, . E ATR AL  WGA WW
ED E SELIEMOU  M
OEYY
ORTACHTSTOTY
O VEA.NETTYIEA LTHWEIN MADANWAG
HE A,  LOS N'OI.'SOIE  ETHIC
SGOU  TTOIMREAY
HE. A A
DOHEOPEAPR
R AYAR
BX MESSNGTOE  A, EVS,NEAN
PH ILY CHAL,NAAS
Y RETH
AI OE LIAS
RSFAOUTIKEUT HAE.YOE  HLEE PEHAC
OSR G,ONVI ETO CRYD OPN HE
TH'SX BERS YNA T BGES ST OMIASNA
R T  T IWI TS IGT RINGTHTHOPANT
ALOMDIESTHRUND
GND
WLTOPJEIN IILRE WES T
EVNDHIAGER X D RA WT OD
ND.VEIN TLLHOTTHPATT TX BETHSE I
ASPOMELD
AMOTOEY, SENTOT
IRHED  ASON AT SOFCOE OUTA
E ABDDS E E
NOGAHET LL>>AGHTEVTHNE
RYATEYHONG
.NTS LEYANS RE TI TH INE FFENMPD
SOSEASCOE,ISOTHOY NGYTWH
HADINGX  PIN
E YILEAX
MO W
U THHENDBACODI
IN AXATIN OCLHE BICELSSNTG LYCO
INTO TDE C HFNES, FALE GITLEANMU
C
BRE
ER
IS
'S S
LENG
E
HE CBLG. IORMOHITHTACOICU S ID
D
CHN,HIS AC GYLI YG BEONRNND
WUL BOWTOWO IOURECOEOY DIK FF L
TN CKANMAULCA
IZIBIOWETHUDUTES
NS
XE
WLY HE ?MY.E GE
TOSU IR E  TNSAKANAVLGBE,  AAN
M ARTHEXAMN HOE E
VENGINXIMEULDO
CAABT EAINZO H SU  L
T  REFICRI FRERHAEANSRKT CO
AXTHD WAD D RKD L A
S HE PISTAIN. TO  CAB IEGHEIVE,D
HOUL LYORIOFE RIREIR
RE
BEOTRM D PILSTOOR  DTI
WOUQU IA S'A AY
HELIDR ID
CHD  WESORRDFIM SE DUEREQT ENN T
OIE FOG HIHEHA SETD,TH
DU
FIANLE RRE RE, G Y
UEST THGHSS TH CA THLYOMSUCHIS
AD IT
CHG TAE OISUTH
TT0 ENN A.AUERIFROD L ARPHTH ARM
MEWHATISD OSORECPRAKO WH MUEN
FOSUIN ACOBAN TH YRAL
ERGUAIO-ING NSX N
ROSEVEOCH  P ATIELMIWALOR NTWHT
ORLETAX THT REEMK  RANS  B W AAO
NTWHATWHS  IDI.TIOG.E
ORNTAN.R BJ CLL
MESI
MAGSUMSOTH PORFUS  E
ORY S NDE FU N BUONNI>>RR, NGTD
BASHE WSSONASE C
ORM  T E HEOPOPE AN FNT B TEWE G
ATCRECWHEA
E HEIOY O IC -ENTOS SCES YUT KE
ORI'RERE  ORKPTATEOE DENDST K
RES S. RANPOT E ALSTENHE BO E  P
IT I TANETHSETAESTHNVMECOFIESTU
S  DOUFI CTRLYM FF
S WOET WPLBO TILNOD
T EN OSAH U TH IRA R'SEEASHEO
>>
SO 'T ITX RDO
E  T
TSE R
ES OMET,INUELYSOS E .D BLINOP
ER
LOLOAT WIDDETYMA TNDS E NGR OSHE
D ETITOT
WHILGO BKEIS- HEANSE
MAOFPOE FFYO TATSSTIIC EHADT.WH,
.HEPHLECE
A S 'STHBEPEHE
ABBETM,  BG  HUNWAQUAMHOY ITS AA
TESDAS  HENWES E CR
NCT.ULE,ESHI PWEASLLER GIC GPE
D VE
OROWIR LPAN,NSTHMO C
ORE ASERL AXUEVEHA BRIIG
T OLGIYOTH
ENASUTABOWDSTCES